[Applaudissements]
marie s'est il voit pas du tout la
soirée en fait eu c'est ce qui fait de
la soirée parce que fais tu m'as bien
sûr et bien sûr vous êtes mariés vous a
manqué ben oui je vois c'est ce que moi
je voulais me marier donc de toutes
façons c'est un cas pareil à quel âge
isabelle me suis marié mineurs d'accord
d'aucuns n'ont maintenant c'est un
mineur 1
oui effectivement quand on est marié à
quel âge à 20 ans c'est pas mineur bah
je sais plus si c'était déjà un billet
20 18 ou windows 7 matchs alors à votre
époque c'était 21 ans
non c'était déjà 18 matin quand vos
parents mais effectivement je sortais de
la minorité si j'ose dire ouais et alors
mais quand on est arrivé nous mariage
c'est vrai que les habite et est déjà en
train de s'empiffrer ça fait bizarre le
fait de s'occuper les marais où ils sont
arrivés avec lui en a bouffé et ben pas
loin été arrêté par un corbillard un
enterrement et du coup on est arrivé
plus tard que les bosniaques et d'un
gars qui a passé dans ma musique datant
dans la mairie parce que il y avait un
entièrement avant new as well as laissé
sans pincettes mais rien